alright hey everyone and thanks for
coming
so yeah I'm one of the original creators
of fighters but as you can guess from
the long list we've already had a bit of
contributors and it's mostly become a
diva of a community project at this
point so how many of you actually do
know piperj like know how it can be used
how the API looks like what are the
general features okay okay so yeah I
guess we'll need to introduce it so
generally like most people and like if
you look on the internet it will
generally be like presented as a deep
learning framework but ultimately if
you're really like I don't only have
half an hour and I really want to talk
about some of the new stuff so I will
need to be really quick with the
introduction and yeah I think it will be
much simpler to actually understand it
if we don't look at it as a deep
learning framework but more is something
like numpy so probably most of you
actually know numpy so numpy is like a
library and python that implements erase
it can be they can be a raise of
arbitrary Python object but most
importantly if you put numeric types in
them they will actually like be
unwrapped from Python objects and they
will be stored in memory efficiently and
also like in native like whatever is the
native computer format you're using and
and so many of the operations on those
arrays become much more efficient like
matrix multiplication or generally like
addition of many numbers in parallel
right so yeah just in case you don't
know numpy - well generally like you can
construct those arrays like this they
can be multi-dimensional so at the top
you have a multi-dimensional layer you
can wrap scalars as well you then you
can do operations on those arrays you
can like take columns
slices whatever check their shape the
add operator is like matrix
multiplication you can generate random
matrices all this and ultimately at the
lowest level torch is exactly like this
so you basically get this nd array
library which which again lets you
manipulate this torch doesn't really let
you put arbitrary Python objects in this
but that's not really the common use
case like you mostly care only about the
numeric types that you want to do some
math on yeah so ultimately at the lowest
love
it's just like numpy but of course doing
numpy exactly would be really silly and
and like that would be pointless it's a
project that's relatively mature and
like there's there's been a lot of work
put into this and it has pretty good
pretty good implementations for all of
those operations already so that will
basically be a waste
so of course torch comes with some new
features and I'll just like give you a
quick overview of what are the most
important points I think that are
beneficial both for deep learning but
not only really like there's there's
something that can be used in in a lot
of domains that just you know requires
some kind of scientific computing
software so first and foremost patrut
really wants to integrate with mump i
ultimately python is great just because
it has this like really huge ecosystem
of like arbitrary arbitrary packages
that can do pretty much anything you
want but really like the the thing that
every single package scientific
computing package at least uses to
exchange data or numpy arrays and so you
really need to be able to integrate with
numpy so just to quickly go through this
we have methods to convert both from
torch to numpy arrays and vice-versa and
so the like most important thing about
this note is that actually it's really
cheap like it's basically cost this
constant no matter how many elements you
have into the in the array it's like on
the order of microseconds so it's really
fast and the way we achieve this is
essentially torch users almost to say
like pretty much the same layout and
memory as a numpy so the data is
actually shared between those arrays so
if you convert to you know one of those
libraries and modify the array within
one of those libraries if you print out
the you know the one on the other side
you'll see that it changes as well so
this is something that kind of lets you
lets you ultimately use torch in like
small parts of your program and only
places where you actually care about
those features and the rest can just use
whatever Python library you really like
and you can just exchange data with no
copying so that's really efficient so
that that's that's that's one of the
important points but then there are two
I think crucial things that are
ultimately extremely needed didn't like
today's scientific computing workloads
so first is accelerate
your support and that's pretty basic and
numpy doesn't have it it actually takes
a lot of work to get it to get this
right and what I mean accelerators
ultimately most of you already have them
there GPUs or some more specialized
hardware but like almost everyone has a
GPU that's capable of executing some
kind of you know specialized languages
like CUDA GPUs or OpenCL on AMD GPUs are
welcome so yeah basically all of this
like kind of array oriented programming
paradigm where like you have all of
those arrays it basically exposes a lot
of parallelism and in your operation so
like if you have two arrays and you add
them you just add two elements the
dependently you have like a lot of
elements at independently of each other
and and and basically GPUs are like
extremely parallel machines and they
really excel at those kinds of things
they've been basically designed to do
those things because that's like how
most workloads and graphics look like
and so so when you have programs like
this they map extremely well to them and
in fact like just by moving the
computation that you have from CPU to
GPU you can easily get like 10 X or 20x
speed-up provided your arrays are like
large enough and just to kind of give
you an idea that it's really easy to do
that in pi torch this is a program that
actually runs on the cpu so you generate
two arrays you add them you print them
if you want to run this on the GPU you
just do something like this so basically
all tensor constructors like this device
argument which lets you specify where to
put the data or if you get like a result
of some CPU computation maybe from non
PI perhaps you can use the two method to
actually move it to a different device
and the the line at the top basically
makes it possible for you to kind of
have scripts that are agnostic to the
system you're running it on so like you
can do quick development on your laptop
that doesn't have like a powerful GPU
don't really want to use it or it's not
even capable of running like it has only
an integrated card and then you kind of
push it to some kind of more beefy
server and it will run on the GPU
automatically so it like detects if it
can actually use this and so this kind
of shows you that it's relatively easy
to have code that's like independent on
the actual device you'll be using
so you can just write your your thing
once and then like depending on the
capabilities of your system that you're
running your script on it will either be
faster or slower but yeah you can still
do that and another I think really
differentiating feature I mean this
popular in machine learning libraries
ultimately but like something that's
missing in a lot of other libraries is
high-performance automatic
differentiation so this is also
something that's been really important
for machine learning because like
basically what it lets you do it kind of
lets your writer function and as long as
it's differentiable you can basically
ask the system for what's the derivative
of you know something I compute it with
respect to something that I use to
compute it and it will do like all the
differentiation for you so you don't
kind of need to you know do this by hand
and like compose the formulas and all
this and and so that that's that's a
technique that's like really important
in many domains as I mentioned machine
learning but also like in engineering
are in finance generally if you want to
simulate something or if you have a
function that you want to optimize which
is exactly the machine learning case for
example this is very useful because like
you can you know take gradient kind of
gives you some kind of local idea of the
shape of the function you're optimizing
so you can kind of try to traverse the
landscape to actually reach the lower
points and also this is again really
easy so basically you just write it as I
mentioned you just write up this
function here it's this polynomial
function then you just evaluate it on
some data and like in here we just
evaluate it on this X and then we can
ask what's the gradient of you know the
output of this polynomial with respect
to its input and so like if you print
this you'll see that it exactly follows
like the simple rules of differentiation
you probably know so yeah that's kind of
the that's kind of the you know the like
if you don't know this that's kind of
the most important part towards also has
a bunch of helpers for training machine
learning models but I don't really have
time in here to cover them unfortunately
so I want to kind of move on to like
what's new in n fighters 1.0 so peiter
has been released in January last year
so it's already been some time and we've
had a really rapidly growing community
which were like super happy about
and you know ultimately when we have so
many people depending on this package so
far we've been in theta we wanted to
kind of push new features quickly we
wanted to experiment unfortunately
sometimes you know between versions you
needed to adapt your code to actually
have them work but I think we've
converged to like a relatively nice API
at this point and so we don't we kind of
want to stabilize so we think that it's
a good idea to actually like release the
1.0 version so so you know to kind of
send a signal to people that actually
this is pretty pretty much ready to be
used in any kind of environment and the
important part is that this is already
available and what's already available
is the release candidate so it's not the
final version it's actually updated I
think daily based on the builds from
like the master branch and the stable
version will be released sometime in
December I think this is not to say that
the current version is unstable
basically like some features might not
exactly be there or may not be like as
polished as we would like them to be and
the final release server so we're still
working on this but like ultimately if
you use it and you you know you have
some code that works with the release
candidate builds you kind of got it to
work you know even though like some
error messages might not have been super
helpful this will also work in stable so
it can still kind of play with
whatever's in there today we already
have documentation for the new things
but it will ultimately get better and at
yeah it will ultimately get somewhat
better in the end the final release like
in a month yeah and then the really
important part that we've been
emphasizing in 1.0 was kind of the path
from research to deployment but I think
it's really important to kind of clarify
what deployment e is so ultimately
pike-perch
the API that kind of I showed you is
like really close to numpy and it's and
you know that's ultimately something
that's that that multiple that many
people are familiar with and it makes
like you know rapid iterations to like
improve on the model you're working on
or in some kind of program you you know
you're working on to solve some problems
really convenient because you just kind
of you just kind of shift around
multiple lines of Python
everything you know adapts magically you
just rewrite your script and and so you
know we believe that ultimately you you
will be going through many many many
iterations of such research cycle but up
but then converge to something that you
really care about and this is something
you want to use in some kind of a final
product and just to clarify what
deployment is in here so it's completely
fine to run Python in production people
are running PI parts in production as
well just from a Python process but
that's not something you really want to
always do and you know there are
multiple reasons for this one if you
have a you know really large-scale
infrastructure just any kind of saving
will be beneficial for you in terms of
power money anything and the second
thing is you know many people want to
take the models they built or just you
know some kind of pipelines they built
and actually port them to run mobile
phones and unfortunately Python is not
the greatest thing to run on mobile
phones because the interpreter is
actually relatively relatively slow in
them it's relatively big if you want to
bundle this it like adds you know a lot
of weight to your application so you
don't really want to do that you really
want to embed kind of a minimal runtime
that can execute something and to into
the app your shipping so the API I
showed you the the numpy like API which
will still you know remain the primary
primary API for pi torch I'll be you
know calling it eager mode from now on
and you know the good things as I
mentioned is that it's really simple to
write and debug it's ultimately the
model that everyone is is very familiar
with if you know if you know how to
program in Python the problem is that
it's really hard to deploy in the sense
that I meant because like whatever you
wrote is really tightly bound to the
Python code that we wrote and so a way
that you know we thought of to actually
kind of get around this to kind of get
your code and your pipeline as data that
you can actually export and run without
python is something called script mode
so script mode ultimately you know at
the lowest level you can think of it as
a new programming language but the good
thing is that you actually don't need to
learn anything because it like follows
exactly the syntax and semantics of
Python the only caveat
is that it's only a subset of semantics
of Python so there are certain things
that are disallowed in those functions
so you can't you know do our betrayal
reassignments of functions and like hope
that everything will work but ultimately
like if you follow a you know certain
certain pattern mostly like avoiding
mutation of objects etc which we can
statically analyze we'll be able to kind
of recover the allness structure of your
code and so two good things that come
from this first is again you can export
this and you can run this from like pure
C environments and second is that it's
actually pretty optimizable so we can
take the code of your pipeline and like
apply some optimizations that are
relatively hard to apply by hand but we
can do this automatically in the back
end to actually make some things run
faster some most common patterns usually
so just to give you an idea of what
works today so those are kind of the
things that are supported in script so
you can work with tensors you can work
with integral and you know
floating-point numbers there is basic
control flow that works you can print
stuff you can get strings you have
tuples of arbitrary things you have
polymorphic lists and you have function
calls and so that's a like very very
restrictive subset as I mentioned there
will be more coming even building like
something that supports this much is
like a pretty pretty big effort but
ultimately like when we tried this is
actually enough to like express most of
the machine learning models that we care
about and also like sometimes you can
actually break out from the subset which
I'll be talking about in the moment so
the important part is this path from
your eager program that you know you do
some research you write the eager
program and then you actually want to
deploy this and the question is how do
you get from the eager program to the
script program and so there are two ways
to actually to actually do that so one
is tracing and another is just using
script straight away so tracing is
exactly this like escape hatch that lets
you not but like doesn't doesn't make us
inspect your code so you can actually
use arbitrary Python features like
whatever whatever
whatever you use is completely fine
there are there are no restrictions
whatsoever so you don't need to do any
code changes the downsides are first
basically how tracing works is you give
us your function and you give us an
example input and so we'll run this
function once and we'll see exactly what
kind of pi torch operations you do on
the arrays right so and we'll basically
like assemble a list of instructions
that will you know be able to replay
this single execution of the function
that we recorded so the this comes with
some downsides like if you have control
flow this kind of data dependent so if
it actually varies at different costs to
this function this won't work correctly
because we'll only see like one branch
of an if or if you're you know for loop
executed five times will only like oh it
will always execute it five times even
though like you know your original
function if passed a different input
would execute ten times like we won't do
that
so that and and unfortunately there is
no way for us since we're not expected
inspecting the source there's no way for
us to actually warn you that like we're
kind of losing some kind of information
like if you use trace you're kind of
asserting to yourself that you that it
is actually a valid thing to do and and
so you know as I said there are a lot of
warnings in here but often often times
this is really what he wants because if
you take convolutional neural networks
as an example that's a picture from the
residual networks paper what you really
want to recover if you want to expert
them to mobile what you really want to
recover is kind of this structure of
computation that you can see on this
graph right so every single box that you
see in here is ultimately some kind of
an operation and the arrow simply
indicates how do you pass around the
data and so it doesn't really matter
like if you use for loops if use
conditionals inside to implement this
kind of model structure like it will
always produce exactly the same sequence
of operations and it's really the only
the sequence of operations on arrays
that you care about so in this case it's
completely fine to kind of throw away
all of the Python bits that you have
around it and
again it's completely fine to like use
this control flow so if I were to
implement a model like this kind of a
simplified version would look like this
so I would probably have a list of some
operations like you know those come to
thee things are exactly the most of the
blocks in this picture so I would just
have a list of them and my model would
simply loop over them and apply some
function and between and so this is
actually perfectly price of all so again
if you were to change the list of
convolute if you were to trace this and
change the list of convolutions the you
know the function that you trace
wouldn't adapt it would be fixed and
essentially it would look like this but
of course like in most cases your
programs if you for example training
machine learning model you really only
construct the the model at the beginning
like you know you might have this list
might have a different length depending
on some command line parameters but it
doesn't really matter because like once
you once you've finished constructing
your model it will stay constant for the
whole duration of the program which will
train the model later so even if you
wrote this function like this it will be
fine too like it will be semantically
equivalent to the trace version if you
use this and in fact if you we have a
torch vision package which is like you
very handy way to train a lot of vision
models it has both datasets and you know
models pre-trained and the ones you can
train for in scratch and I'm pretty sure
that like you can take any model from
the torch vision package that's written
there and you can safely trace it on a
single input that's like even randomly
generated and that will give you a trace
that's a completely valid for training
or for a later export yeah so that
summarizes tracing and as I mentioned
there is another way to do this because
sometimes you really do care about this
control flow and you really wouldn't
like to lose it and that's this and
that's the scripting way so tortured
script is an annotation that you can put
uncertain functions to kind of assert
that they will be written in the subset
of Python that we support so you're just
again you're still writing Python like
you're not and pretty you're kind of you
don't have another programming language
embedded you don't really need to learn
anything
you and we'll simply statically analyze
the source of the functions that he
annotated like this so control flow is
recovered correctly because we'll see
that you have like an if or you know a
loop inside your function but again
you're restricted to this subset and the
cases where this is useful for example
our recurrent neural networks so so
basically this is a function that
computes a recurrent neural network and
why this is important is because you
have this loop which like depends on the
size of the tensor so if you think about
the networks they're like recurrent
neural networks are sometimes used you
know you can you can refer to them as
sequence to sequence models so they map
a an input sequence to an output
sequence and the nice thing is that the
sequences can have different lengths so
like if you're processing natural
language a sequence might be a sentence
and not all sentences have equal length
so in this case it's like really
important to actually retain the leg to
actually be able to run this loop a
different number of times so tracing
wouldn't work in this case but you know
this function is written in the subset
that we support if we do require you to
put some type annotations on this so we
know actually what's what and like if
you can actually unpack those things
correctly so we do support both the
Python 3 syntax and the Python 2 syntax
for like compatibility reasons although
you should really use Python 3 at this
point yeah and the important part is
that trace and script really mix
seamlessly so if you have like a big
thing that you don't really again care
how you implement it so you want to
trace it except there's this single loop
inside that you really care about
preserving and and so so it's completely
fine to like put the script annotation
on this small thing and then just trace
through the whole thing and and once you
get to it it will actually not trace the
it will like still run the scripted
function but it will actually not use
the instructions it emitted it will
actually just copy/paste the graph so it
will retain the for loops or like
contraflow that's inside and again if
you use something that you trace
previously in a script function because
again script
in support function calls it will again
like not go through some external
mechanism it will be a first-class
function call in this like programming
language that we designed and the
important part again is that we support
function calls and they're not only
within the language we also support
function calls to Python so obviously
when you call back to python from a
scripted function you will no longer be
able to like export your model because
it will again not be able to run without
python you have some Python references
inside but it allows you to like really
quickly kind of iterate on those things
so when you if you if you were to take
your your your your script that's
written in Python and like transfer it
we don't want you to kind of jump on a
you know huge journey again if transpile
all of your code to this up to the you
know format we support we kind of want
you to you know plop those annotations
kind of you know function by function
you can verify that it works every step
along the way and and also later like if
you have something that's completely
converted to script you've exported your
model but then you want to go back to
the research cycle like you want to
change some things try out some new
libraries we don't support in the subset
it's again completely fine to just
remove a few of those annotations in the
places you want to edit it just runs
this regular Python you know you can
debug it as regular Python code and and
you know it's still it so keeps working
as long as you don't export it it's
completely fine you can still run this
and as I mentioned the important part is
that you can really run this in native
C++ environments so once you export such
a model there is basically one liner at
the top in here that can load it in C++
using our own library and you can run it
on any tensor in C++ because we also
have a C++ API now which I'll be talking
about in a second as well yeah so
exporting is one thing but I also
briefly mentioned that it's also an
optimizable subset so this is very much
work in progress so you shouldn't really
expect wonders once you annotate those
things we've been really mostly working
on getting it to be robust and kind of
give my zero messages and you know
generally be a nice thing to
work with and performance optimizations
can be done like later in the background
things can magically start getting
faster and faster but basically the
problem we're trying to solve hate here
is that like if you use a like vanilla
model that like maps really well to some
fast primitives like you know that if
you run a recurrent neural network on a
GPU there is like an Nvidia CUDA n n
library and that implements this network
and it's really really fast and like
it's really hard to match it and so if
you write the same network but using
like regular Python you know torch
Hobson Python your performance will drop
like a few times at least like 5 X 10 X
is actually relatively reasonable and so
something and and so you know in most
cases if you're just training vanilla
models this is completely fine because
they always map perfectly but if you
actually want to change some small
things inside you suddenly fall out of
the subset and so you have to pay this
performance penalty and this is
something we want to avoid so for one
variant of analyst TN that we've been
benchmarking kind of just annotating it
with script already gives you like a
three times speed-up so again it's not
like it won't magically improve every
single model it really depends a lot on
what your model is and what how our
optimization how well our optimizations
that we currently have mapped to it but
you know there are certain cases where
you can really find very noticeable
speed ups yeah and now I'll have to
really quickly cover the extensions an
interface that we've recently added is
currently in beta it's not really very
much part of the release this can still
change so you really shouldn't kind of
depend on some production projects on
this like the part for loading the data
for loading the the exported things is
should be stable but like some of the
other things I'll point out which ones
are they they can actually change
between this and next release so you
really shouldn't depend on this so
extensions have been around for like a
few months now I think basically what
they let you do is they let you port
some of your code from Python to C++
either because you want to interface
with some other
C++ libraries or because you have custom
CUDA kernels because again you want to
speed up your thing so you know it's an
example of a function in here that you
know this song basically allocates a new
tensor multiply some other tensor by two
and then just launches a CUDA kernel and
so everything you need to do to expose
this to Python is actually just put
those three lines at the bottom this
uses a PI bind 11 library that we ship
with it's very convenient and like it
will automatically generate all of the
code that kind of converts between
Python and C++ types back and forth so
that gives you a really easy way to
writing those C++ programs the only
difficulty you might still be facing is
how do you actually compile them because
that's not usually very easy in C++ but
we do provide two ways to actually do
this for you so if you want to be
distributing your extension you can like
use a setup tools based method which is
like you know the canonical way to build
to create Python packages but if you
really want to hack on something really
quickly there is also like a one-liner
that lets you import such C++ code so
you basically give it a list of sources
like relative to the to the script I
think and it will basically first time
you call it it will compile it and give
you the Python module for this the next
time it will just load load the love the
precompiled module again and then you
can simply use this function as if so
like you know and here it it took like
two tensor arguments returned a tensor
at the bottom here it's pretty small but
like it's but you you can basically use
it as a Python function that liked again
takes two tensors returns a python
tensor your program doesn't really even
notice it called like into your C++ code
and just to quickly go over the
interface I don't really want to get
into details again but that's an example
of how so that was this table part this
has been here for some time and it will
be stable now we get to the kind of
preview part so that's how you would
defined in simple neural network and in
Python and if you were to do this the
same in C++ that's how it would look
like if you have a training loop in
Python that's how it looks like if you
were to do this in C++ it looks like
this so it's really like mostly just
syntactic difference
between the two languages but ultimately
we do have an API like if for some
reason you really need to run in C++ we
really think you should use Python if
you can but like if you if you want to
embed in some runtime environment that
only has a C++ API that's still
sometimes better to just write the code
straight in C++ and know we have an API
that exactly match is pretty much
one-to-one with our Python API and you
can do that so most of our packages for
neural networks grading based
optimization data loading serialization
Python integration and toward script
again are there they're part of the
preview so they might change but if you
want to if you want to try you can see
I'm really running out of time but
generally like the final thing is we
have a new distributed back-end it's a
complete overhaul it has like new
abstractions it has some performance
benefits and some of the nice things is
that it actually lets you write fault
tolerant programs so for example you
know if some of your notes fail you can
still recover and you can also like
implement elastic sizing on like you
know on spot instances and on some cloud
providers to kind of lower the costs of
your training finally there is we're
also working on integrating with cafe -
it's not very much user visible but
ultimately cafe 2 is like merging with
piperj to become Pytor 1.0 they have a
lot of great mobile kernels so the
mobile sorry will be generally getting
better yeah
so I run out of time generally petrich
is supported by a lot of institutions
both academic and and corporates we have
a really vibrant community you can go
into the forums people will help you
they'll answer your questions and yeah I
hope I hope you'll appear somewhere in
there as well so thanks a lot
[Applause]